Apple September 12th wonderlust iPhone
event is now just days away and it just
dawned on me that all the leaks rumors
and speculation is about to be over and
Apple's about to either blow everyone
away or disappoint all of us fans
because man has this event been hyped up
like crazy over the past few months but
for now we've just got some final last
minute leaks rumors and updates that
have come out since Apple officially
announced their event last week so let's
jump right into everything new starting
with the iPhone 15 lineup we've recently
had more discussion that the iPhone 15
Ultra could be the name instead of the
pro Max for the larger model imagine boo
guess that there might be a pro Max and
an ultra based on the different Ram
configurations of the a17 chip but Mark
German said that right now there's only
going to be one high-end model that has
a 6.7 inch display named either the Pro
Max or the ultra so he's currently
unsure about the name but I think we
just got a new leak showing that it will
be called the pro Max and the ultra is
coming next year we recently had some of
the wallpapers for the iPhone 15 Pro
leak at least the design and multiple
people have made some renders showing
what it could look like it does look
really cool but it does look really
similar to the ones on the 14 pro we
also had michoco confirm the colors for
the Pro Models being gray a certain
silver slash white black and a darker
blue Sonny Dixon actually showed those
exact colors off and one of his tweets
so I think it's perfectly legit and he
also showed us some of the iPhone 15
colors the regular model but they all
look really subtle and kind of
pastel-like lacking saturation so I'm
not sure if those are fully accurate as
you can see we have received our dummy
models right right here four of them
this is the pro Max model this is the 15
plus and one thing I did notice is that
we do have that subtle curve around the
edge that feels quite nice I honestly
think that the curve on the real 15
lineup will be better and we also have
the action button only on the Pro Models
while the regular models stay with that
ringer but other than that they're
honestly just so similar to the 14 that
a lot of people might not even notice
any difference we then had Dan Roy on
Twitter show off Apple's new fine woven
case which at the time was kind of
sketchy but then Majin Buu confirmed it
with a bunch of different photos
including some very interesting details
on how the fine woven twill technology
will work for making this case feel
really smooth and premium and he also
mentioned that the price could be around
a hundred dollars for those cases which
is insane and then a little bit later
Sonny Dixon confirmed the those cases
with a live Hands-On video of the case
in action and finally Mark German
actually reposted it basically showing
that this case is real and it's coming
then kasutami-san on Ax shared all of
the new colors for this fine woven case
with black Mulberry taupe Evergreen
Pacific Blue Wisteria antique white
butter yellow orange and pink and the
main idea behind this case is that apple
is actually getting rid of genuine
leather for their iPhone cases in the
name of the environment and that's
according to Mark German who says this
switch is coming along with a bunch of
different leakers to me this means a
huge opportunity for a lot of the third
party case makers like Nomad who make
genuine leather cases they are gonna
sell like crazy because apple is no
longer gonna offer real genuine leather
and then moving on we had multiple
companies including anchor reveal a
bunch of new USBC Chargers cables and
accessories which shows how confident
they are that apple is going to be
ditching the lightning port and
switching to USBC for good on the whole
15 lineup on top of that we had Belkin
and Mophie debuting their new G2
wireless chargers which goes hand in
hand with the rumors that Apple's iPhone
15 lineup is going to support G2
charging at speeds of up to 15 watts
even with third-party Chargers which we
used to only get with Apple's official
Max save charger so this is really good
news and then some people have recently
leaked and speculated that Apple could
be upgrading the official Max save up to
20 watts in order to make it kind of
feel exclusive with an additional
benefit if you buy Apple's charger on
top of that more and more lists have
recently been coming out discussing the
price hikes of the iPhone 15 models with
digit times senior analyst Luke Lin
chiming in after many others so I think
it's pretty safe to say that we should
expect the pro and pro Max models to get
between a hundred and two hundred
dollars more expensive moving on we got
a new leak from Aaron p613 on X that
door Dash is working on live activity
support especially since we're expecting
the new 15 and 15 plus models to finally
ditch the Notch and start coming with
the dynamic Island just like we have on
the current 14 Pro Models Mac Rumors
also just made a very nice article
summarizing all of the new changes to
the camera on the entire iPhone 15
lineup including the new 48 megapixel
camera on the regular models which will
actually be different than the sensor
that's on the current Pro Models with a
faster F 1.6 aperture so it might
actually be bit better than on the
current 14 pro and curiously the
telephoto and Ultra wide cameras are
apparently changing on the 15 Pro Models
with slightly higher resolution and of
course the 15 Pro Max will have a
periscope lens which I believe is going
to be variable to adjust between around
3x to 6X Zoom length tranforce also put
out an update saying that the iPhone 15
camera upgrades will be the star of the
show tipping the scales for potential
buyers now you might have seen Max's
recent video talking about all of the
new camera details and updates so if
you're interested in watching it check
it out over there after this video is
over and finally the last update for the
iPhone 15 leaks is a bit of controversy
in terms of the new USBC port a survey
created by cell cell showed that 63 of
random iPhone users said that the switch
to USBC could motivate them to upgrade
to an iPhone 15 with 37 percent of them
saying they would upgrade because they'd
be able to use a single cable for their
iPhone Mac and iPads but on the other
hand a UBS analyst David Vogt said that
the new USBC Port could actually deter
some customers from upgrading because
they'd have to change over their cables
everywhere which could cause people to
wait a little bit now in my opinion I
think this is a good change and people
already have a bunch of USBC cables
especially since Apple will be supplying
a nice braided and color matched USBC
Cable in the box that's 50 longer than
the previous ones now we recently had
this leak that started showing up on
Twitter or X about the new iPhone 15 Pro
gray model and I think this is actually
fake because if you look closely the
bezels don't match up the cable is not
color matched and the cable is the same
length so I think this leak was fake but
with that said those were all the new
leaks for the the iPhone 15 and now
let's jump into the Apple watch as we
know we're getting the series 9 which
will be very similar to the 8 except
with a new chip and wireless spec
upgrades and a new pink color and same
thing for the ultra 2 with a new chip
but it's now also going to come with a
black titanium Metal finish but apart
from that Mark German reported that
Apple has just started experimenting
with 3D printing to create devices
starting with the series 9 models the
technique is called binder jetting where
apple is able to print a device's
outline at close to its actual shape
using a powdered substance a second
process then uses heat and pressure to
squeeze the material into a substance
that feels like steel and then it's
refined with Milling so basically this
could help with Apple's sustainability
and eco-friendliness and their profit
margins as well going further the Apple
watch is gonna have a new magnetic watch
band and it could even use the new fine
woven material same as the new fine
woven cases and probably the same color
options according to recent leaks but
getting even crazier Apple's leather
watch bands may be completely
discontinued for the Apple Watch series
9 and the name of the environment Mark
German even said that he heard Apple was
offering insane discounts on Hermes
watch bands with some 850 dollar bands
going down all the way to 85 dollars but
only for employees he states that
they've been trying to clear inventory
the best they could before this event so
Apple could potentially be fully getting
rid of genuine leather bands and cases
but other than that not much else is
going to change with the Apple watch so
now let's move on to the new airpods Pro
with USBC we got a recent report from
Mark German that the new USBC airpods
Pro will not have any other Hardware
changes so it's just going to be a
simple swap to a USBC case and that is
all a simple update that honestly
doesn't matter that much since the
airpods support Max save charging and
Apple watch Puck wireless charging as
well and then finally we have some iPad
updates now I still think there's a
chance we could be seeing a new updated
iPad Mini or iPad Air at the September
event but I'm not as sure right now
because we haven't really heard much
leaks on that now Mark German did
mention that Apple was really close to
releasing a 14.1 inch iPad this year
kind of like a larger sized budget iPad
but they chose not to even though they
did get really close and there you guys
have it those were all of the fresh
latest leaks and rumors right before
Apple's event so if you're as excited as
I am go ahead and subscribe right above
and check out that iPhone 15 camera
specs leak video right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]